throw them at wall show we are suffering
from a crisis of masculinity in our
culture and it's only getting worse as
anyone who tries to speak up for men
inevitably gets silence we'll talk about
all of this and how it relates to the
Andrew Tate phenomenon today also the
Kevin McCarthy Saga enters another day
but does any of this really matter not
really students at a university complain
about my dangerous presence in biased
incident reports that have been made
public and they are just wonderful read
through some of them today and the media
has spent all week denouncing football
for its violence but I'll explain why
violent sports are actually a good and
necessary part of society all of that
and more today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
foreign
if you're someone who has always wanted
to read and understand the Bible but
you're not sure where to start then
check out the Bible in a year podcast
from Ascension the Bible into your
podcast is currently the most popular
religion podcast in the U.S millions of
people have listened to it and twice
it's hit the number one spot on Apple
podcast in the Bible in a year father
Mike Schmitz reads the entire Bible in
35 daily episodes providing helpful
commentary Reflections and prayers along
the way what better way to start the new
year than this you can find the Bible
into your podcast with father Mike
Schmitz for free and your favorite
podcast app or on YouTube plus you can
follow along with a special reading plan
to help you better understand the story
unlike any other Bible podcast Bible in
a year follows a special reading plan
that organizes the books of the Bible in
a way that helps listeners understand
the story you can get this reading plan
at ascensionpress.com Welsh if you want
to start reading and more importantly
understanding the Bible this year go to
ascensionpress.com Walsh to download the
reading plan for free that's
accenturepress.com Walsh to download the
reading plan for free
today I want to begin by talking about
the crisis of masculinity in our culture
because that is what we're facing
there's an epidemic of confused
directionless depressed broken young men
and it's incredibly clear to me that
this is rooted largely though not solely
in a scarcity of male role models
specifically a catastrophic lack of
present devoted fathers in the home this
crisis is also driven by while at the
same time helping to create a culture
that is deeply hostile to young men a
culture which seems dedicated to
demoralizing them and preying on their
weaknesses
and this problem is very personal to me
because I have two sons with two more to
be born sometime in the next couple of
weeks if not a couple of days which
means I will eventually be sending four
young men off into this cultural void
and so I spend much of my day every day
thinking about how to prepare them for
it
that is also the lens through which I
view the Andrew Tate phenomenon Andrew
Tate of course is the former kickboxer
turned social media personality Who Rose
to prominence as a voice of the
so-called manosphere with a message
directed primarily at young men and over
time he amassed a large and devoted
following within that group but not
really becoming widely known outside of
that demo until big Tech decided all at
once several months ago to kick him off
of every platform and they did this
ostensibly on charges that Tate
expresses outrageous and objectionable
views allegedly which they decided no
one should be allowed to say and more
importantly no one should be allowed to
hear
but not for the first time however the
the effort to erase and unperson someone
only had the opposite effect of making
them more influential and more famous
and better known than they'd ever been
before I could say in my case
um I'm one of I think probably millions
of people who before they erased him
from everything I I I'm not sure I'd
ever even heard his name before
so I became acquainted with him because
they were trying to suppress him
which was a positive result in my view
if for no other reason than the fact
that the sensors and D Platformers
deserve to have their efforts backfire
in such spectacular fashion so anytime
they try to cancel someone and that that
person becomes more famous I'm happy
because they deserve they the the
cancellers and uh and uh the Platformers
deserve to have that result now the most
recent update on Tate is that he was
arrested last week by Romanian
authorities on charges of sex
trafficking he says that this is simply
just another attempt by the powers that
be to punish and silence him meanwhile
the powers that be say that he raped and
sexually exploited multiple women that's
what he's accused of
now as for my opinion on the man I I can
say nothing about the criminal charges I
simply have no idea whether he's guilty
or not his accusers will have to prove
his guilt in a court of law when it
comes to the less serious matter of his
allegedly offensive opinions I would say
that
some of his opinions are indeed
objectionable in my view though
certainly not deserving of censorship
while some of his opinions are not only
correct but insightful and important
he's a human being in other words not
right all the time not wrong all the
time I tend to concur with Ben Shapiro's
taking Andrew tatus he expressed in his
podcast a few days ago Tate is very
often good
at identifying some of the problems
especially as they pertain to the
situation that men face in the culture
so for example here's a video he posted
on his Twitter page a few days ago cut
from an earlier interview with Tucker
Carlson and this is an example of the
good stuff uh let's listen to that
tell us what your message is to young
men yeah so I think that being a man is
very very difficult I think that men's
issues are largely overlooked a lot of
young men growing up today that feel
very disaffected they feel invisible the
agendas that are being forced down their
throats or not agendas they align with
or they feel Affinity to or agendas they
want and I basically just say to men
look it's a very hard life you're gonna
need to get up work hard go to the gym
strong body is a strong mind you're
gonna have to reject listening blindly
to everything you're told reject the
slave mind think of yourself get a
strong network of Brothers work aside
them don't tolerate low quality people
in your life which means don't tolerate
men who just smoke drugs and play video
games and try and build and create a
reality full of high quality people in
which you can resist the programming
that the Matrix drives the influence you
with and grow up truly happy
now all that is true it's good that he's
saying it it's also enough on its own to
get you de-platformed you don't need to
say anything more offensive quote
unquote than what you just heard In that
clip to earn the ire of the left and of
our cultural Elites but where Tate goes
off the rails is in the remedy that He
suggests now some of his prescriptions
are reasonable and correct go to the gym
work hard uh build networks be around
high quality people I mean these are all
I don't disagree on on any of those
counts
yet he also brags about sleeping with
many different women he promotes a kind
of ostentatious materialism saying that
the best way to be a manly man is to
make a lot of money and buy fancy cars
and show off your wealth he says things
like this tweet a couple of weeks ago he
uh tweeted this Genghis Khan had endless
women and 200 children as reward for
Conquest I am the most searched man on
the planet I have conquered Earth I am
the highest status male on the planet
females do not expect loyalty from me
they only expect that of lesser men
now this is not masculinity an
over-the-top blustering kind of ego
declaring yourself to be the highest
status man on the planet this is a sign
of insecurity not strength I mean any
time you feel the need to announce to
the public especially on social media
how great you are
um every single time you are doing that
because you are insecure no secure
person ever feels the need to do that no
man comfortable with his status feels
the need to brag about his status
worst of all Tate suggests that loyalty
is a virtue of lesser men which could
not possibly be more wrong
any man can be disloyal okay anyone can
be disloyed any man especially if he has
a lot of money can sleep with a bunch of
different women and discard them in fact
any man with not a lot of money can
still do the same if he's willing to you
know go out and buy the affections of a
two dollar hooker for a few minutes
that's that's not impressive
much less a sign of masculine strength
real masculinity and also real joy and
contentment in life is found in the man
who remains loyal and devoted to his
family
this is not only the more difficult path
but it's the more rewarding path
by far on both counts
loyalty and humility
are both Virtues Of The truly masculine
man and yet they are virtues that Andrew
Tate explicitly militates against like
he's against those things and we'll say
so
so while he gives young men some good
and important advice he is he still
winds up leaving them ultimately
where they began which is stranded alone
confused
but the real question that we should be
asking in regards to Andrew Tate isn't
whether he's right or wrong about
everything he says
rather the more important question the
more interesting one to me
is why his message resonates to begin
with
this is the thing the left never stops
to consider because every time an
annotate is certainly not the first it
won't be the last
every time a new figure comes along with
a message directed at men
okay our cultural overlords will swoop
in immediately to discredit destroy and
silence that person every single time
these self-appointed Gatekeepers have
never met a man with a message for men
who they didn't find problematic and
misogynistic
that's because while Tate May Veer off
in various wrong directions as far as
his Critics on the left are concerned
there is no Direction he could take the
message that they wouldn't consider
dangerous and toxic
well there is one I mean if he was
preaching the gospel of self-loathing to
men if he was telling young men to hate
themselves and apologize for being who
they are
he was talking about toxic masculinity
then they would shower him with praise
they'd give him a doctorate you know and
uh he'd have a book deal he'd get
glowing interviews on Good Morning
America
that is the only thing anyone is allowed
to say to men if you're addressing men
specifically okay in the public sphere
if you're saying hey men and then you
continue to have a message for them
the only acceptable message as far as
our culture is concerned is shame on you
stop being that way be more like a woman
and that's precisely why Andrew Tate and
guys like him resonate and they find
such an enthusiastic and devoted
following they are speaking to men in a
way that isn't resentful isn't
accusatory isn't condescending
and they are among the only people on
the national stage doing that so the
audience naturally goes to them to the
guy who isn't spitting in their face it
kind of makes sense
and as I said at the beginning a huge
percentage of young men are raised in
homes where there is no fatherly role
model
often isn't a father present at all and
and in so many other cases there might
be a father physically present in the
home but he's not present emotionally
spiritually psychologically he's not
present any other way he's just there
he's a lump on a log
so they're not taught how to be men how
to harness their masculinity how to
constructively use all of the energy and
aggression that's brimming inside of
them
out in society they're greeted with
accusations and Scorn and they're told
that they must suppress their
masculinity feminine feminize themselves
then a guy like Andrew Tate comes along
and says no it's good to be a man it is
good to be tough and strong and
masculine
they prefer to listen to him and they
are justified in preferring him
considering the alternatives
the correct response to Andrew Tate then
isn't to silence him and condemn his
followers it is instead to say yes
he's right it is indeed good to be a man
and then to follow that
with a better and clearer vision of what
it means to be a man and how a man
should behave what his roles and Duties
are what direction he should go
because that's what these young men are
looking for they're looking for
direction and guidance
if you don't have that to offer
then just step to the side they're much
better off listening to Andrew Tate
than to someone who believes that the
best version of a man is a woman
what we should be telling young men
what I will and do teach my sons is that
a man
has a noble calling to protect and to
provide he is uniquely equipped to
fulfill this role and was made by God
for that purpose he is a protector he is
a provider that's what a man is supposed
to be
that is what every man is supposed to be
every single one
and any man who is not that who is not
doing that
will will will fall into despair
because he is useless
and the worst thing that a man can be or
feel is useless
nearly every man who has committed
suicide and the suicide rate among young
men is increasing
and nearly all of them it's it's in part
because that's how they felt about
themselves useless there's no point to
their life nothing for them to do
so this is what a man is made to be
and most men are meant to find the
ultimate fulfillment and expression of
that role of protector and provider in
the family as father and husband not all
men though some men are called to serve
in another way
but all are called to serve all are
meant to live their lives in service to
something greater than themselves no man
is meant to live aimlessly wandering
from place to place motivated merely by
the drive to satisfy his desires from
one moment to the next
no man can find fulfillment in that life
but that is the life many are condemned
to because they've never been shown
another way
because because the cultural powers that
be have decided that we're not allowed
to show them another way our culture
tells men that they're not called to do
anything in particular that their sex
should have no bearing on what they do
or how they interact with the world
and we call this freedom
but it's the sort of Freedom you give to
a man in the desert by taking away his
compass and his map
you take that all away and you say uh
see you're free now to wander and go
nowhere
and die
that's not Freedom that's despair
which are two things that are very often
conflated these days
is it any mystery that these wandering
men would so eagerly follow the first
guy who comes along and seems to know
where he's going
if his map isn't as reliable as he
thinks or claims
well it's better than no map at all
because if you're completely lost
you might as well follow whoever claims
to know the way even if he takes you in
circles you won't be any worse off
and at least you'll have some company
for a while
we cannot push away all of the people
who are trying to guide these young men
only to replace their voices with
silence
because that is simply abandonment
and we have abandoned young men for far
too long
now let's get to our headlines
if you're looking to upgrade your style
this year without breaking the bank then
check out the true classic teas for a
limited time only my audience can get 25
off true classic tees with code Walsh at
trueclassic.com whether you're at the
gym or on a first day you can never go
wrong with a true classic tea no matter
no more boxy fit or loose collars true
classic fits a bit tighter in the chest
and sleeves but leaves more room in the
Torso for a relaxed t-shirt feel but
true classic is more than just a t-shirt
company they offer an entire activewear
line and they just released new
button-downs shirts as well you can
build your entire wardrobe with true
Classics true classic has a 100
risk-free guarantee with a 30-day return
policy with 200 000 five-star reviews
it's no wonder these shirts are quickly
becoming a menswear go-to get 25 off at
trueclassic.com with code Walsh that's
25 off with code walls at
trueclassic.com free shipping is
included with purchases over one hundred
dollars
NBC news headline McCarthy makes
concessions heading into third day of
house voting for speaker article says
Fierce Republican infighting over who
should be the next speaker has paralyzed
paralyzed the House of Representatives
preventing lawmakers from being sworn in
delaying staff hiring and stalling the
gop's legislative agenda on Thursday the
house enters its third day of the new
Congress without a speaker under the new
house a new GOP majority until
Republicans have enough votes for a
candidate all other house business
remains at a standstill during the sixth
speaker votes this week 20 conservatives
have stuck together to deny GOP leader
Kevin McCarthy of California the 218
votes needed to win the speakers gavel
because Republicans want a paper-thin
majority in November nearly all of their
222 members will need to agree on a pick
for speaker
the chaotic process moves to a seventh
ballot when the house reconvenes at noon
uh on Thursday but while McCarthy allies
and foes remain deadlocked on Wednesday
there were some real signs of progress
after the sixth vote failed McCarthy and
his most trusted allies huddled with his
most fervent opponents for more than two
hours in the first floor Capital office
of majority whip uh the first floor
Capital office majority whip Tom emmer
most emerged from the meeting saying
that there was incremental progress okay
now
I have the same opinion about this that
I had yesterday
which is that and I'll have the same
opinion tomorrow if this continues in
the day after
um which is that Kevin McCarthy is a
milk toast establishment shill just an
empty sort of nobody a nothing and uh
you and and you could literally put
anything or anyone in his place and
you'd have the same results if not
better
um and so he deserves to be enduring
this humiliation and I hope that they
keep it up I hope this continues for
another month I hope it goes I hope it
goes forever
I do not because the story is
interesting it really isn't interesting
at all
as I said yesterday nobody cares about
this drama outside of DC and political
pundits
you know no one is no one is uh uh I
mean you walk up to any average person
on the street and you say hey what do
you think about this Kevin McCarthy Saga
they're gonna say uh Kevin who what is
it oh well uh there's this guy Kevin
McCarthy he wants to be speaker of the
house and he's not winning the votes
isn't that fascinating
it's not fascinating it really is I got
to say this again to pundits and uh DC
media this is not that interesting okay
you can keep using work this is this has
never happened in history
oh okay
there are a lot of boring things that
haven't happened in history and then
they happen and they're still boring
so that's not that's not why I wanted to
continue it's not because I find this so
absorbing and fascinating
uh I wanted to continue because number
one it is uh and most importantly it is
a vote of no confidence in the
establishment that's really what this is
this is a at least a small select group
of Republicans who are saying we have no
confidence in these people and we're not
just gonna get in line because that's
what you do that's really the whole
argument right it's Kevin McCarthy
doesn't have the votes
and there's he's not he's not it's not
like he's been selected by God to be the
Speaker of the House
this is not something that's written in
the stars all right he doesn't have the
votes
so the whole lot what argument is there
for the the Republicans who aren't
backing down what like why should they
they don't want him
and they're supposed to vote for who
they want they don't want him so they're
not going to vote for him
the only argument
against them and in favor of them
standing down and getting a line is just
that like this is the establishment
that's what you're supposed to do
this is just what you're supposed to do
this is what people do in this situation
well that's not a good enough argument
and I think that is increasingly
becoming not a very that is not a
compelling argument to people anymore
in fact that argument cuts the other way
because when normal people hear well
this is how it's always done in DC
but without any other context a normal
person hears that and says well then
like we probably should be doing it
differently I don't even know what it is
you're talking about it's probably it
probably is not the way it should be
done
the other thing I like about this too is
that it's um
is that it it it's grinding uh the House
of Representatives
and then to a large extent the
legislative branch of the federal
government in it to a standstill which
is what we keep hearing all this
panicking about we can't do anything
we're not able to we're not able to do
anything we're we can't hire staff and
what about the committee assignments and
everything
uh with the lawmakers can't even be
sworn in
and there's all this frantic panicking
over it and it's the same kind of
panicking that you hear every time we're
uh coming up on the precipice of a
government shutdown and it's the same so
what are we going to do with the
government
but then it happens
and you look around and you realize it
doesn't matter nothing changes
so the House of Representatives has been
has been ground to a standstill so what
what difference has that made this made
no difference
and that's what they don't want you to
see they don't want you to notice that
that's the main reason why they're
always so paranoid about government
shutdowns
it's not because there are Services the
government's providing that they really
feel passionate that they want to
continue providing those Services it's
more that they don't want you to notice
they don't want you to notice that you
don't notice it when the government
shuts down that your life continues as
normal
it's the same mental it's the same
reason why somebody who's working you
know if you work in an office or
something and you know that your job is
redundant and useless and you know that
you don't really do anything around here
well you're going to be very afraid to
take a vacation because you don't want
your bosses to notice that when you
leave and you're not even here nothing
changes
you don't want them notice that so uh
you're you're going to be reluctant to
take the vacation
it's the same thing
happening right now they don't want they
don't want us to notice that when it's
ground to a standstill it doesn't matter
makes no difference
Our Lives continue as normal
because even when this is all settled
whether it's settled today or tomorrow
in a year from now you know uh that then
it's well now the House of
Representatives can get down to business
what is that business exactly what is it
that you people do
so you can hurry up and just do nothing
so I think this is all great all right
um
speaking of great there's a great
headline from the college fix UW-Madison
liberals physically sick and hurt by
Matt Walsh event
now
I say this is great but it's really not
I I hate to think that I had this effect
on people I don't I don't I'm uh you
know this about I'm a very sensitive
person and I want everyone
to be happy when they I can't even say
that with a straight face uh I could say
anything with straight face and I
couldn't say that University of
Wisconsin-Madison students faculty and
staff feared a conservative event event
that criticized gender ideology
represented a hate crime against women
and would
hate crime against women
so this is an event really it's what is
a woman College Tour and my whole sort
of point is that women exist and that's
a hate crime against someone to say that
women exist is to commit a hate crime
against them
I'm committing a hate crime against
women by affirming their existence
okay
um and would promote violence against
LGBT individuals according to documents
obtained by the college fix
the fix recently obtained bias incident
reports through a public records request
for complaints made against the Young
Americans for Freedom event featuring
Matt Walsh the event was about
transgenderism and shared a name with
his what is a Woman movie students staff
and professors were left angry hurt
physically sick at the thought of him
coming to Campus based on complaints
primarily filed before the event
the documentary highlights the problems
with gender ideology was released by The
Daily wire the conservative commentator
in 2022 the October 24th event sparked
protests and dean of students Christina
olstad released an official message
through Instagram that condemned Walsh
as harmful
um and anyway we knew about a lot of
this let's get to the complaints okay so
these are the actual bias incident
reports that were filed and the public
records request and so now this is being
released and here's what one student is
a male student who complained I feel the
movie is better described as a hate
crime against women especially
transgender women in a video form so let
me translate that for a sentence this is
a hate crime against women especially
men in a video form
this is a hate crime against women
especially those women who are not women
in particular is what he's saying I
Believe by allowing you have to host
this event they are not only spreading
hatred across campus I think they're
also in violation of a few RSO policies
and will create a potentially unsafe
environment similar to similar events
hosted to other universities
the same student felt physically sick
while researching the movie upon
researching this documentary I found a
wealth of evidence that this has clear
themes of transphobia misogyny racism
ableism and ageism
ableism in ageism where is that in the
film okay I know where the transphobia
is
where did we get to the ageism
I mean I interviewed an older man is
that ageism so I talked to Don suker
who's a great uh it was a great
interview
so I guess just by by talking to him I'm
committing agents I don't know it has
created a great upset within lgbtq
spaces on campus many of us feel unsafe
and frustrated that campus is allowing
an RSO to put on this event
um and then uh let's see other
complaints there's another complaint
that said allowing for such a
transphobic speaker to be present on
campus with such a large platform shows
queer trans and non-binary students
staff and faculty that their experiences
are not valid and their persons are not
safe
their persons are not safe
um
I am angry and hurt that the community I
love which was a which has a home here
on the women in gender studies
Department floor was so blatantly
attacked a gender studies Professor
named Finn enke also submitted a
complaint the speaker is known not only
to Target gender and sexual minorities
as well as women the yaf is known to
intentionally inflame and draw a
response from marginalized and feminist
communities
um
I don't feel safe anymore so on and so
forth okay
you know all this panicking
it went on and uh every every of every
campus that I went through they're
panicking over my presence
but now we can look back and we see in
hindsight that I went through that
entire College Store tour we we stopped
at I don't know seven or eight different
campuses
and I only murdered three people the
entire time okay that was less okay
fewer
then one person per campus did I murder
and yet all of this over that
I practically didn't kill anybody except
for the three that I did
kill this straight up killed him by
saying my opinions right into their
faces I just said my opinions
and they were in the audience and the
opinion went into their ear and they
just they dropped dead only happened
three times
um in reality of course this is
when I see this kind of thing
what what I see is it's not I I I think
this is this is always wrongly described
by people on the right as well they're
being over sensitive they're being
snowflakes as I've explained many times
that's not the right term here we should
stop calling this since sensitivity this
is not sensitivity uh many of these
people are sociopaths they they
sensitive is the last of their problems
okay they don't have a problem being
sensitive a sensitive person is is has
has if anything is like overly
empathetic you know has an overabundance
of empathy that's what a truly sensitive
person is and of all the flaws you can
have like that's not the worst
um it's pretty good flaw to have
actually to be a truly sensitive person
is this is not a problem that I struggle
with but if you're a truly sensitive
person and I know some people like this
you know truly sensitive is like it's
like you you yeah your feelings are
easily hurt but at the same time uh you
have a lot of empathy and your feelings
easily get hurt on behalf of other
people because you care a lot about
other people
that is not this okay these people that
is not their issue
you don't care about other people at all
they only care about themselves this is
their fragile ego that they're concerned
about and nothing else
but also it's a recognition
of the Frailty and fragility of not only
their egos but of their belief system
that's that's what this actually is that
they at some level
whether they want to or not they
recognize
um
that their entire belief system is
is a is just a pile of sand
and that it can be blown away
um with the slightest Breeze
they recognize that it's uh you know a
house of cards whatever metaphor you
want to use here
they recognize that
um they cannot withstand the slightest
challenge
and so their only move
well there'd be two moves there are two
two possible responses when you realize
that your world view your belief system
is utterly
frail and weak and cannot withstand any
scrutiny at all there are two possible
directions you can go one is to confront
that reality and then say well I guess
there's a problem with my world view and
I better start to reassess
that's a really scary thing to do and
most of these people don't have the
courage for that takes courage
okay to be very very wrong about
something and especially about something
that is so fundamental
and then and then to to realize that and
not run from it
and to be willing to reassess that takes
moral courage
okay
um
it's almost like you you know it to go
to another metaphor mixing around if
this Jenga Tower and you notice that uh
there's one brick here that's a little
bit precarious and you're willing to
pull at it knowing that the entire thing
might come tumbling down that takes
courage these people don't have that
courage and so they're not going to go
that direction instead they're gonna go
the direction which is the other
possible response when you realize that
your world view is fragile the other
possible response is to try to shut down
and silence and if you can't do that
then just scream at anyone who
challenges you and that of course is the
is the uh
the option that they that they choose
okay headline uh this is a CNN Headline
about a truly historic glass ceiling
shattering moment for the trans
Community uh and hopefully this is
something that all the people that we
just we heard from that were upset about
my event accusing me transphobia uh
hopefully this time to make them feel a
little bit better uh I want you know
something encouraging for them so
uh here it is headline is Missouri
carries out first known execution of an
openly transgender person for 2003
murder
uh the headline says Missouri are the
article says Missouri carried out the
first known U.S execution of an openly
transgender person Tuesday when Amber
McLaughlin who was convicted of a 2003
murder and unsuccessfully sought
clemency from the governor was put to
death by lethal injection McLaughlin was
pronounced dead at 6 51 PM the Missouri
Department of Corrections said in a
written statement spokesperson did not
say if McLaughlin had issued a final
statement
McLaughlin's execution the first in the
U.S this year is unusual executions of
women in the United States are already
rare
and they remain just as rare as they
were before this man was executed
um it says prior to McLaughlin's
execution just 17 had been put to death
since 1976 when the U.S Supreme Court
reinstated the death penalty after a
brief suspension and uh so anyway
this is a transgender person and this is
the headlines are all over the place
saying that that and before he was
executed we kept hearing that there the
state of Missouri is about to execute a
a trans person for the first time
and most of the the headlines especially
mainstream Publications
they were careful to not go all the way
and explicitly State their argument
which is that this person should not
have been executed all because they're
trans like the trans should have been a
a get out of execution free card
that was obviously what was implied by
all the headlines all the Frantic
headlines say they're about to execute
the first trans person clearly what
they're trying to say is that we
shouldn't do it because the person is
trans
uh but most of the articles in CNN and
New York Times They didn't come out
completely and say that clearly that was
the implication but in any case
this is true inclusion this is equity in
action folks
so congratulations to Amber for her is
rather I should say achievement
extremely well deserved extremely well
deserved
uh this was a person who by the way this
is you know when you when you anytime
you read articles about someone who's
executed
um rarely anyway
do they lead off as they should by
telling you what this person did you
always have to read through you read how
sad it all is the person actually and
then like 15 paragraphs down
you finally get to the oh by the way
this is what this monstrous scumbag did
to deserve this
and in this case
um so-called Amber McLaughlin and I'm
not sure what his real name was this
this was a the transition happened on
death row quote unquote transition
so it doesn't say what his real name is
here but so we'll just go with this
fake name Amber uh
a murdered
brutally murdered his well he was his
ex-girlfriend in 2003.
and before that in the 90s had been
arrested and charged and gone to prison
for raping a 14 year old girl so this is
a child rapist murderer
and yet we're supposed to be
upset somehow
that he is no longer with us
now I will say that I I
made this same comment on Twitter about
this being a glass ceiling shattering
moment
um God forbid I make light of the
execution of a monstrous child raping
scumbag murderer
and I did that on Twitter and and some
people on the left trans activists were
very very upset with me in fact there's
an account uh Reddit lies is the account
and it compiles examples of people
saying crazy things on Reddit and so
apparently on one of these forums
the trans activists and leftists are
wishing death on me nothing new about
that I mean they wish death on me every
day but the wishing death on me in this
case specifically because I was
celebrating the execution and making
light of the execution of again a child
raping murdering piece of garbage
so here's a couple uh comments from this
Reddit Forum if Matt Walsh was murdered
it would make my day at this point I'm
so sick of that repulsive effort that I
have no issue wishing death on him
someone else agrees I wish someone would
just effing redacted this guy already
murder me
um world would be a better place
someone else do just needs a good
old-fashioned ass beating bonus points
if he gets beat up by a trans man
it would be so effing dank
uh who says dank anymore is that really
is that an expression that the kids are
using no matter how that person
identified they were convicted murder
and rapist so yeah I had it coming okay
well this is this is one person that has
uh this is the one moment of Sanity in
this Reddit Forum one person pointing
out that okay yeah it's a trans person
who
murdered and raped people
someone else says referring again to me
now I hope all his skin falls off that's
creative I want to kill him with an
aluminum bat
and once again just to remind you they
are talking about me here not the uh not
the rapist and murderer
um
that bat should have a rusty nail so
that now there's a little okay so then
so someone says that they want to kill
me with them on a bat and then and then
there's this little conversation that's
back and forth where they're kind of
brainstorming all the different methods
that they could use uh you know it
should be a rusty bat they should there
should be a nail in it
and this is in defense
once more
of a child raping murderer
that's what they're upset about okay one
other headline here it's something else
from last week that I wanted to cover
and well I wasn't here so I couldn't
um mention it now though Fox news
headline Buffalo police arrested 10 for
looting amid the deadly winter storm
officials in Buffalo New York said
Wednesday so it's last Wednesday night
that 10 arrests have been made in
response to looting following a deadly
winter storm that ravaged the region
over the Christmas weekend the Buffalo
Police Department said the arrests were
conducted by its newly created
anti-looting task force the group was
formed after reports of break-ins to
businesses as the storm halted daily
life in the city
um on Tuesday Buffalo Police
Commissioner Joseph gramoglia warned
that looting would not be tolerated this
isn't people stealing food and medicine
and diapers he said they're destroying
stores they're stealing television
couches whatever else they can get their
hands on they're opportunists he said at
a press conference
so
um
that was for the major winter storm last
week and uh and we had you know we got
down to negative temperatures here in
Nashville negative two degrees other
places the the weather was even worse
and this led to looting but don't worry
because what we learned from some
leftists on Tick Tock is that uh the
looters had every right to do what they
did they'd have a right to exploit and
take advantage uh of this situation as
they so often do and um here's one tick
tocker explaining why
I live in Buffalo this is a 33. this is
my car that's been buried in all of this
snow since last week and this is outside
my Granny's house a tree that's been
there since my aunt was a child safe to
say that it's a
[ __ ] out there right here go y'all
goblins who don't even live in the city
which by the way the Q-tip people are
the last ones to ever talk about
somebody stealing anything y'all
wouldn't be in this country had it not
been for y'all stealing it so y'all are
more focused on people looting and
trying to get necessities and things
that they need and yes the TV is a
necessity thing then the people who are
literally freezing to death in their own
home freezing to death outside because
this city did not shut down the way it
should have Byron Brown want to get on
here and talk about we told y'all we
knew this was gonna happen but why
didn't you close businesses when you
should have why you got everybody
rushing home at noon when the you know
storm is starting and now people are
literally dying in their cars because
they can't see and yeah it was that bad
I went out like at eight o'clock in the
morning before it started and by the
time I got out of Wegmans right it was
like maybe 9 30 10 o'clock
and it was bad and that was just the
beginning of the storm so if you don't
live in Buffalo even if you do live in
Buffalo you feel like you're better than
because people are out here stealing and
you would never first of all if you are
a Mayo monster that is how your
ancestors got everything from stealing
people are out here trying to get toilet
paper people are out here trying to get
you know just small little food from
Family Dollar y'all
capitalism still everything that you
need babe because at the end of the day
this city continuously fails us whenever
we have any type of emergency Byron do
better
okay
male monster she calls white people
which I take exception to for a number
of reasons not the least of which is
that I um I I hate the Mayo I was just
calling for the execution of people that
enjoyed mail the other day so uh this is
no different from what we hear from the
left all the time infamously AOC you
know of course said that looters are
just out stealing bread to feed their
families
and yet
after the looters as we heard from the
police chief you know after the Reuters
looters run through a Walmart or Dollar
General or whatever it is that they're
stealing from the bread aisle is always
conspicuously left untouched not only
are they not stealing bread but it's
like the one thing they won't steal the
one thing that they won't steal are the
Necessities that that does those are all
of the the sections of the store that
are left untouched
um and that's because these are not
starving people who are out desperately
scrounging for resources
that's not what this is
these are vultures scavengers
victimizing their own community
exploiting a crisis to steal from their
own Neighbors
the businesses that provide Necessities
to their own communities there they are
exploiting and victimizing
and this is also something to keep in
mind you know when you hear about
so-called food deserts okay what is a
what is a food desert what do you think
the food desert would be like an actual
desert is a food desert it's one of the
things that defines a deserts they're
not a lot of they're not a lot of
resources of that kind
that's not what what it means when we
hear about food deserts this is an
effort
on the left they've come up with this
terminology
and it's an effort to
support the claim that there is still
this systemic racism against black
people in the United States
and um they have to get increasingly
desperate when they're when they're
trying to you know find and locate this
mythical Phantom systemic racism and so
they end up talking about things like
food deserts and so food desert is is
you know places especially in inner city
often in Black communities where there
are not uh there are not as many stores
and restaurants and grocery stores and
that sort of thing as there are other
parts of the city
that's a food desert
although like even if there were none at
all if you're living in a city you're
you're never going to be more than like
a five minute Uber ride away from some
kind of store
but if there are these food deserts if
there are
you know grocery stores and restaurants
that are shutting down shop in these
communities or refusing to open up in
the first place
maybe this is part of the reason why
I mean when you Prey Upon the businesses
in your community
and you Loot and Rob them then they're
going to go away and and then other
potential business owners are going to
look and they you know if you've got
someone who wants to open up
their own restaurant their own grocery
store and they're trying they're
thinking of where should I put it
they're going to tend to put it in safer
places
where they're less likely to be
victimized in this way
seems rather obvious I realize but you
know it still needs to be pointed out
against
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
well today's coffee often comes with
hints of soy and social justice Black
Rifle delivers an entirely different
experience bold strong and delicious
Black Rifle coffee is the coffee that I
choose to get me through the day Black
Rifle coffee company is veteran founded
and operated their mission is to help
service members successfully transition
from the military into entrepreneurship
they provide assistance to Veterans who
seek to launch businesses of their own
with the goal of helping more companies
like Black Rifle become a reality as for
the coffee itself while Black Rifle
sources the most exotic Rose from around
the globe all coffee is roasted here in
the US by veteran-led teams of coffee
experts Black Rifle has all the best
Brewing gear thermoses mugs apparel
designed all for folks who love country
and coffee so you can go to
blackriflecoffee.com use promo code
walls for 10 off coffee Coffee Gear
apparel or when you sign up for a new
coffee Club subscription that's black
riflecoffee.com with promo code Walsh
for 10 off Black Rifle coffee supporting
veterans and America's coffee
Edward Jones says Matt an important
thing to remember about most aged 18
plus porn consumers is their desire to
remain anonymous they won't be they
won't give identification information to
a porn site for fear of it being leaked
okay
well then don't just just don't look at
porn then
that is look that's a perfectly valid
concern all right
um I wouldn't want to give my driver's
license information to PornHub
right and and they they might claim that
they're well we promise we're not going
to do anything with this data
right well far be it for me to question
the Integrity of smut Peddlers and the
porn industry but I'm not sure that I
would trust that so I get that you know
I I'm when I suggest these age
verification and I say that they
um I'm not I'm not saying that it's
actually a good idea for you to go and
give your give your credit card
information or your uh you know or your
driver's license information to to
PornHub
but that's that's your issue like that's
your that's your problem it's it's uh uh
because the other potential solution for
you is just to not go to the site and
it's not like you have some sort of
god-given right to access Internet
pornography without any barriers at all
that right does not exist that is not a
thing that is not a right
um that is a privilege that people have
had in this country for a long time and
shouldn't have
and so what this really is is it's a
balancing it's a it's a uh what we're
doing is we're balancing the right of
children to be protected from this
versus your right to access pornography
as quickly as you want without giving
any of your information away so those
are the two competing sort of claims
here
and I'm going to say that the right of
children to be protected it wins out
every single time without even having to
think about it
um
Cajun King says as a citizen of the
state who was of age it's still just
annoying I ain't giving my information
to a porn site a lot of comments like
this once again good idea don't go to
the porn site it's an even better idea
moose chuckle says there was once a time
I would be against age verification for
internet porn for me it wasn't about
inconvenience it was about the shame
that I would have putting my info in
that was 20 years ago now I'm all for it
I have a kid and it would protect them
furthermore maybe a little shame is what
we need to help prevent others from
falling into watching and being obsessed
with porn and that's what I indicated
yesterday that I think
the the resistance to age verification
these very basic regulations
that every other adult oriented business
is expected to abide by the resistance
against it like intellectually it makes
no sense at all there are no coherent
arguments against it and I've always
said that you know so what it really is
you got these people that they don't
they want to they want to find their
masturbatory material their masturbatory
AIDS and they don't want anything you
know standing in the way they don't they
don't want to be inconvenienced they
don't want to have to waste 30 seconds
they want to be able to get to it as
quickly as possible I think that's part
of it but then the other part is what
you just said which is there's the shame
too because
even having this conversation about how
kids need to be protected from it that
is to acknowledge that porn is a toxic
disgusting thing and then having to put
your information in it's like it's it's
even if they don't steal your
information or invade your privacy it's
still just
it feels all the more shameful that
you're going through that additional
effort to access this stuff
um but once again that's
your issue uh that that does not
outweigh the safety concerns for
children
and if you feel shame looking at porn
well you should it's a shameful thing
you're watching other people have sex
it's a shameful
uh
voyeuristic sort of thing
uh let's see Cameron says I like this
for many reasons think of all the people
who are too lazy to get IDs before voter
registration will Skyrocket next cycle
well that's true although voter
registration skyrocketing for me is a
negative if you are familiar with my
opinion on voter turnout which is that I
think it should go down not up
um Kenshin says government needs to stay
out of our Lives it should be up to the
parent to monitor what their kids do
online not for the government to punish
Everyone by requiring ID to watch porn
this will just backfire horribly now
we'll be able to look up who's watching
and uh use that as a weapon against them
imagine a politician getting caught
watching some extra nasty porn and his
opponents using that to bribe him into
passing a bill they want
that's an interesting like plot of a
movie that you just made up in your head
I'm not sure that it really qualifies as
an argument though
and government stay out of our Lives
that's also not an argument that is not
an argument
okay that is uh that's a that's a slogan
that's something you put on a poster
it's not an argument
and it's not even a good slogan
because nobody thinks that government
should stay out of our Lives completely
unless you are an advocate of there
being no government unless you are
actually an anarchist which I'm guessing
you aren't and in fact nobody really is
because even the people that claim to be
anarchists I mean them most of all tend
to be the ones that are relying on
government services and all the rest of
it so nobody's action all right that
doesn't exist nobody is not
everyone agrees that there needs to be a
government that government is necessary
to some extent it's just a question of
what should they be doing
you know in what scenarios in what ways
should they be
um
stepping in and interfering in our lives
if you want to put it that way that's
the question
it's not a question of if it's a
question of
in What scenario when you know that's
that's the debate
so
of all the things that government should
there are a lot of things government
does that it shouldn't do
but when we list the things that the
government should do
is protecting children from the
multi-billion dollar smut peddling
industry does that make the list of
things government should do and I would
say absolutely yes
Snooki G says the thing about the Demar
Hamlin incident is unless you're a
family member who is solely focused on
his well-being holding multiple thoughts
about the situation seems completely
normal it's like seeing a car accident
and after the ambulance carries off the
horribly injured person wondering how
the uninjured people are going to get
home
this is interesting because I almost
made this exact point and I didn't
because I had been talking about it for
too long already and I didn't want to
draw it out but this is just another way
of illustrating the point from yesterday
I I 100 agree with you and I think about
this all the time it's like
um
you know anytime there's a tragic event
you always have we don't have to review
everything we talked about yesterday but
you have the the outrage mob and they're
out there they've got these booby traps
set up and uh they're looking for anyone
to step on it so that they can then you
know pounce on them and virtue signal
and so many of these rules are kind of
structured around this idea that when
the tragedy happens
um you're not allowed to like talk about
anything else for an arbitrary period of
time you're not allowed to have any
other concerns related to that tragic
event uh other than just simply saying
how tragic it is and and that's that's
the rules they they set up
and yet
we know that that's just not like nobody
operates that way we know that in the
face of tragedy and horrific events
we very often have other concerns
including logistical concerns so Skip
Bayless a couple days ago mentioning the
issue of how are they going to
reschedule the game it's a logistical
concern it's not more important than the
person's life but it's a logistical
concern it's not it's a it's a it's a
normal thing to think about I wondered
the same thing everyone else wondered it
and and before you get on your high
horse about that just think about all
the times as you point out Snooki G
think about all the times that you have
been stuck in traffic because of a
horrific accident
and for all you know someone is dead and
if they're not dead they're at least
terribly injured and their life has been
irrevocably changed and you're sitting
in traffic and you're very sad about
that but you're also looking at your
clock because you're worried they're
gonna be late to your appointment you're
gonna be late to work you're gonna be
late to getting home you're gonna be
late to you know making it out to
Applebee's like who who has done that
before every single human who has ever
been in traffic has had that situation
has had that experience
where a terrible thing has happened
you're sad about that
um but you're also you have other
thoughts as well and you're even
concerned about the logistics
as well so like we've all been through
that
yet there's this game of even though
it's a thought we've all had uh someone
makes a mistake of expressing that
thought out loud and we all pretend to
be offended by this thing that we all
know we thought ourselves that's the
game
it's a new year but uh leftist companies
are still up to their same old dirty
tricks ladies it's time to help you guys
wash out the woke once and for all with
Jeremy's razors uh new line of men's
Staples and uh he'll love the tea tree
and argon oil infused shampoo and
conditioner exfoliating charcoal body
wash or if these are so traditionalist
who prefers something to hold up uh hold
on to the oatmeal and citrus soap scrub
uh will work as well they smell great
they're made right here in the USA by a
Men's Grooming company that doesn't hate
men imagine that shop the new Jeremy's
hair face and body wash collection and
kick woke out of the bathroom and when
you visit the store do it through my URL
so I get the referral bragging rights as
well which is very important so go to
dailywire.com Walsh treat your man to
some great Jeremy's razors products
today that's dailywire.com Welsh now
let's get to our daily cancellation
thank you
one thing we've all learned is that
there is nothing worse than a national
dialogue very often after a tragedy or
Scandal of some kind we're told by the
media that it's time for a national
dialogue sometimes the dialogue is about
gun violence or hate or homophobia or
sexism or mental health and it's always
the media that announces this dialogue
and the media that proceeds to have the
dialogue a dialogue that always turns
out to be more of a monologue the media
talks about the subject that we're all
supposed to listen that's how the
dialogues are always meant to go so this
week we and and by we I mean they the
media have been having another dialogue
and this one is about violence in
football in light of the Demar Hamlin
incident yesterday reporters even tried
to get the president of the United
States to chime in on this subject of
violence and football but they were
rebuffed due to the fact that the
president of the United States is well a
vegetable listen
I think the NFL is getting too dangerous
no look
the idea that you're gonna have
you got
guys that are
six eight
340 pounds
running uh four eight forty
I mean you know
it hits somebody with that kind of
forward now that's not what happened
here
but I just think it's a
I don't know how you avoid it
ah well he has a point it's impossible
to say what his point is but I'm sure he
has one over on The View uh the football
experts sitting around the table had a
slightly only slightly more coherent
conversation about the topic but still
very stupid
right I mean my kid played football he
was recruited for college and he got a
terrible hamstring injury getting hit
and um I saw him clap to the ground
thank you and um he went through
physical therapy for six months and he
realized at that point uh oh I could
that could happen to my brain yeah and
so he quit and he did he quit and it was
a very hard thing for him because he
loved doing it
um and I but I don't think it's going to
turn people away from the sport because
I mean I went to Notre Dame it's like
Faith Family football it's a big deal
and it's 105 billion dollar industry so
45 of Americans think that tackle
football is appropriate
heterosexual men voted the most support
for kids uh doing football and
conservatives were more likely to
support youth tackle football just
saying just saying heterosexual men
enjoy football so it must be bad
with a take like that Joe Behar Joy
Behar May uh may have just earned
herself a show on ESPN actually
meanwhile the news media has contributed
to the National dialogue with headlines
like these
fans grapple with football's violent
pull after Hamlin collapse and we're all
complicit in the NFL's violent spectacle
and then the terrifying collapse of
Damar Hamlin and the everyday violence
of football but the first place prized
for insufferability has to go to the
Washington Post article which is titled
after the hoopla all that's left is the
NFL's violence this is written by a
woman named Robin givan who has likely
never actually seen a football game and
couldn't discern a first down from a
field goal but the piece begins with
this paragraph
from a distance from outside the circle
of fans and aficionados professional
football is both confounding and
enraging it's America's most popular
sport and is also deliberately
unspeakably violent it's a particular
kind of violence that's less about
accidental collisions adrenaline fueled
fist fights or even a singular
articulated blow football violence is
wrapped up in machismo militarism
Swagger and patriotism it isn't a sport
that thrives despite the violence
but because of it
now she's exactly right about the last
couple of sentences there and that's
precisely what makes football so great
she goes on for many other uh paragraphs
continuing to criticize football in
terms that just make it sound all the
more appealing to many of us especially
many of us men she says football is a
particularly American sport although it
certainly has fans in other countries
notably in Germany Britain and Canada
but the NFL doesn't have the sort of
international rosters that one finds
among Nate the Nations baseball and
basketball teams there is no American
football World Cup football is America's
violence
in football the player wears the where
players wear their helmets and pads to
provide them some protection but all
that gear is also a recognition that the
game is in fact predicated on men
injuring other men they give each other
a bruising they put a hurt on each other
they go to war Americans love their
football they're loyal to their favorite
teams fans admire football players
athleticism they're impressively complex
tactics and the competitive Spirit of a
Super Bowl but in the last decade much
of the Romanticism that once surrounded
football has disintegrated to more
clearly reveal the racism and the
corporate offices the sexism within the
culture and the enduring physical pain
of the game all that's left is the
violence Americans settle into their
seats for that they tailgate in
anticipation of their volatile pastime
this orchestrated pummeling of another
team the walloping of another person
the Winner's Victory is a violent one
so to review
um football is violent Macho
militaristic brutal patriotic and
uniquely American
this is supposed to be an argument
against football but it ends up being a
better advertisement for football than
anything the NFL would come up with
these days and that is a better NFL
advertisement than any NFL advertisement
I have seen in 10 years
and that's the funny thing here is that
the media is discovering football's
violence at precisely the moment that
the NFL is doing everything it can to
neuter and feminize the sport and make
it less violent professional football in
fact has never been less violent than it
is right now
and yet now is the time when reporters
are asking the president whether
football is becoming too dangerous
now whatever else you might say about
the sport there is no doubt that it is
actually becoming every year
significantly less dangerous for better
or worse
but even with all the additional focus
on safety
and the new rules introduced every year
to make the sport less physical and less
brutal
um still it remains a sport a contact
sport
and so injuries are possible
serious injuries are also possible fatal
injuries are extremely unlikely and
incredibly rare but still possible
anybody with a brain knew this already
every player knows this we have all
always been aware of the possibility
which is why it doesn't make sense to
engage in some sort of fundamental
reassessment of the sport when the
possible thing which we all knew was
possible happens Damar Hamlin is a
tragic occurrence it's not new
information though
it's the sort of thing that everyone
knows can happen
and so when it does happen it just
doesn't make any sense to say well we
got to reassess all of this it's like if
there's if there's a terrible car
accident and somebody dies in The Cars
Demar Hamlin thank God is has is didn't
die in this is has survived so far but
if there's a terrible car accident
and you're sad about the car accident it
doesn't make any sense to say well now
we have to reassess and and rethink of
everything about the highway system I
was like we always knew what why would
this you always knew that there were
accidents
so why is this causing you to think
differently about it
but putting that aside for a moment
and even putting the NFL aside let's
consider football itself as a sport
despite any rule changes or updates to
the equipment it is still a
fundamentally violent sport that's true
and and that's what it always will be
is that a bad thing no it's not
in fact it is a good and healthy thing
it is good that football is violent it
should stay violent it is good to have
violent Sports
okay we should have violent Sports if
anything we should have more of them
because a violent sport like football is
among other things
a relatively safe relatively safe and
relatively productive outlets for male
energy and aggression
okay there's a reason why many of the
media articles being written and
freaking out about football are being
written by women
because football is not no matter what
the NFL is trying to do football is not
for women there might be some women who
get into it but it's not really forward
it's not for you you don't understand it
you're not meant to understand it this
is actually a man's thing
this is why violent games have existed
in every society going back to primitive
times they are a means of channeling and
harnessing male aggression
part of the reason any boy or young man
starts playing football is that he
enjoys the contact the violence the
opportunity to hit someone yes that is
one of the things that is going to drive
a boy to play football again is that he
wants to hit someone
boys enjoy violence they do that might
make your tummy hurt to think about you
might put your uh hand on your forehead
and faint over the thought that boys
enjoy violence it doesn't change the
fact that they do boys naturally enjoy
violence my sons are constantly
wrestling and beating the hell out of
each other for fun my daughters never do
that with each other my boys do it all
the time
they love when I join in and wrestle
with them as well which I often do it's
what guys do it's how we're wired in
football or in any number of similar
Sports a boy learns to channel that
energy according to the rules and the
Playbook and in service to a greater
good which is the team now they're not
out fighting for their country they
aren't actually warriors on a
battlefield there isn't much really at
stake it's just a game sure but the
focus on the team working towards a
common goal utilizing that violent
energy in a disciplined and targeted way
between the whistles between the
sidelines this is all very good we need
to have Outlets like this we need to
have ways for young men to harness and
use that brutal masculine violent energy
that scares Washington Post columnist
and Joy Behar
the problem though is that we are
steadily removing all such Outlets from
society we're giving boys fewer and
fewer opportunities to be rambunctious
and violent in controlled and productive
environments
instead we attempt to suppress those
Tendencies entirely and feminize them
but it doesn't work it never will
and we again and again react with horror
when the male aggression we've been
trying to suppress and which has which
has few healthy outlets for expression
anymore spills out in far more dangerous
and destructive and chaotic ways on
street corners in classrooms Etc
here's the fact of the matter
you will never have a society without
Violent Men it cannot exist it never
will
the only question is whether men will be
given constructive avenues for
channeling and using that aggression or
not
if you choose not
there will be a price to pay
we are already paying it
and that is why the people trying to
cancel football
are instead themselves today canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block and you can become a member and
use code wall should check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you over there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]